Rosa Parks nous dit qu'il y a toujours
quelque chose que nous pouvons faire.
du temps que nous avons passé ensemble
parlait de liberté et de liberté de
religion liberté de voter pour la liberté pour
tout le monde
[Musique]
simplement parce qu'elle est entrée par la
porte d'entrée alors que la porte de derrière était trop
encombrée il l'a attrapée par la manche
et l'a poussée hors du bus  cela l'a rendue
assez folle, elle se souvenait qu'elle
avait évité de prendre son bus pendant un moment
et quand j'ai refusé et que j'ai été emmené en prison
[Musique]
avec le plus simple des gestes, elle a aidé à
changer l'Amérique et à changer le monde
[Musique]
où nous devions atteindre  l'égalité des droits
avec un être humain
[Musique]
J'espère que nous continuerons à faire
tout ce que nous pouvons pour vous aider
car ils ont tous un avenir [
Musique]
appelée la première dame des droits civiques,
elle est restée attachée à la  cause
de la liberté dénonçant
l'injustice ici et à l'étranger
[Musique]
vous